so let's get started shall we voters
certainly sent a message to the two main
parties in this week's local elections
but what was that message both Teresa
May and Jeremy Corbyn have interpreted
it as a call for them to get on with
brexit and redouble their efforts to
reach a deal but is that right well
joining us now from Leicester is the
Shadow House secretary Jonathan Ashworth
thank you very much for being on the
program this morning delighted it feels
like we should start with those local
election results you've been in
opposition now for nine years the
government is tearing itself apart on
brexit and frankly doing very little
else and yet you lost seats at the local
elections I mean why isn't they be doing
better so we should be doing better and
I can't pretend I'm not disappointed
that we've lost seats but it is worth
emphasizing and the Tories got
absolutely monstered result for the
Tories since it isn't there but I think
it's important I mean that this is the
worst result for the Tory since about
1995 they've lost over 1300 seats when
they were when they were briefing that
only lose around a thousand which was a
part of their expectations management I
mean that we should have done better of
course we should but we made gains in
imported marginal seats in the South in
Thanet in Worthing we've won councils
back in Midlands marginals like Amber
Valley so we did make progress but of
course there were other disappointing
results across the country and we have
to reflect upon that we have to
understand why that's happened and we
have to work harder as a party to regain
the trust of people so that we can form
the government but we have made progress
in the sorts of marginal seats
particularly in the South that will
decide the next general election it's
interesting isn't it because you're
talking about making progress and some
seats in the South but in Labour's
traditional heartland in place it's like
Bolsover like Ashfield like bolton like
Walsall you've been losing ground it
feels as if you're doing well with
graduates but perhaps losing touch with
some of your more traditional support
base and you say that you are making
progress in marginals but actually if
you look at some of the analysis done by
for example a professor Michael Thrasher
and today's Sunday Times the implication
is actually a further away from winning
a general election because you're
actually down on where you would have
been at the last general election so I
just wonder well are you managing to
find the right coalition of supporters
here well I think Michael Russia's
analysis in the time so she shows labour
gaining seats constituency seats on what
it on what we have today but not enough
to farm a government outright so we do
need to make further progress but it
does show us inching forward if you like
and and I just think I think I think
that the situation is more complex if I
may say so than the way in which it has
been caret character eyes din recent
days yes we've done badly in former coal
fill seats in Nottingham sure like ash
feel really badly but next door in
Mansfield another nottingham charcoal
field see we've actually took the
morality and that's a seat we have to
win back off the Tories and next door in
another nottingham shikou field seat
getting we actually increased our result
by our vote sure by eight percent and
took seats off the Tories so the picture
is much more complicated I'm here you
know I hear I'm sorta in my hole outside
my house in Leicester in Leicester we
actually took 50 53 out of 54 council
seats so the picture is more complicated
than some of the immediate knee jerk
reactions that we've seen are on Twitter
in recent days if I may say so I can
understand of course no one's arguing
that there are areas of the country
where labour is making gains but overall
I just still think that it is pretty
astonishing that you're down 86 seats
and control of six councils no no I mean
we are down and I say that I so that's
disappointing so we've got to look at
the areas what if not done very well
I mean if we looked at these if you if
you did a direct read across to
constituencies which you shouldn't which
doesn't always read across I've been
doing these sorts of interviews for
years now and they don't always
necessarily read across a subsequent
general elections but on these results
we would have lost dabbing off for
example but there are other seats we
would have gained but I don't know us to
be losing constituencies anywhere I
wants us to be gaining constituencies to
form the next government so we have to
work harder to win the trust of the
British people we have to look that we
have to you know we should be pleased
that we've made progress in some
southern marginals and Midlands
marginals
but recognize that we've gone backwards
in other marginals we have to respond to
that by
would emphasize the tories got
absolutely monstered in this set of
local government elections though worst
results since the mid nineties and there
are lots of Tory MPs who now who if they
if these results were repeated and
general election for example in Plymouth
and places like that
those Tory MPs that would lose their
seats and labour candidates would become
Labour MPs in those marginal
constituencies I mean some people think
Jeremy Corbyn is part of the problem
here and your colleague Lisa Nandi who
represents Wigan and just the kind of
place that of course you need to win
said yesterday Jeremy came up on the
doorstep a number of times
negatively is here help or hindrance
well jeremy corbyn's leadership allowed
us to have that remarkable general
election was all in 2017 by the way in
2017 I was doing similar programs to
yours Sophie on election night so on in
the 20 around the 2016 local government
elections and we were being told or what
a terrible set of local government
elections for labour and then of course
when they led you we said we had no we
have but we have some remarkable
victories in seats that people didn't
expect us to win and everyone told us at
the start that election campaign that we
were going to get absolutely hammered
look I'm not complacent I mean please
don't get me wrong I'm not saying no
this is nothing to worry about it's all
fine not at all I'm just I'm just trying
to step back and recognize that we have
have made progress in marginal seats
particularly in the south and places
like Fannett in Plymouth and some of the
Midlands marginals like em and the
valley but we need to work harder I mean
and we need to do more to win the trust
of the British people we need to be
talking about the big issues that affect
people's lives like future let's talk
about some of the schools that they're
being talked about some of those so a
big issue shall we because it is clear
that a message was sent by voters and
I'm interested to know what your
interpretation of that message is Jeremy
Corbyn said after the results on brexit
an arrangement has to be made a deal has
to be done so is that the next steps
labour trying to do a brexit deal with
the government what the doc kinds of
different motivations for the way in
which voters voted in these in these
elections and you can't always interpret
that interpret them as just sentiment
about brexit but on the issue of the
deal that we've seen a lot of that lot
of speculation in the newspapers today
and I do think it's actually quite
disappointing that it looks like
ministers and sorry spin doctors have
been briefing about what's happening in
the negotiations we've entered these
negotiations in good faith they should
be confidential at this stage because if
you want to get an agreement we have to
be able to respect the position of those
suss around the table and they all we
seem to be reading all kinds of things
in the newspapers today so I would say
to those Tories negotiate and this isn't
really the best way to go about it to be
frank but look we've entered those
negotiations in good faith we've said we
said in our general election manifesto
two years ago that we accept the
referendum result and that we believe
the correct way to bring this
desperately divided country back
together is an arrangement where we'd
have a permanent customs union deal with
our with our ability to have a say over
trade deals a single market relationship
and guarantees about workers rights but
the problem about the way in which the
negotiations are going and I'm not I'm
not part of the negotiations but as I
understand it although the government
are trying to sort of redress up their
custom the customs union office they
haven't really shifted and the key thing
is the government want to be able to do
their own trade deals and my concern
that is if we have a trade deal with the
United States for example that could
mean Trump's Trump's America and big
private health care cooperations getting
their hands on NHS contracts I'm not
prepared to countenance that it's why we
need instead a permanent and
comprehensive customs union arrangement
well with where we do our trade deals as
part of the European Union not not a
trade deal which allows the Americans to
come in and buy various different NHS
contracts and I think that is a real
problem if the Conservatives have
prepared to go down that line our NHS
mustn't speak what some beast for sale
the problem is in the US you talk about
the government not being prepared to
shift its position so I'm just trying to
work out if Labour is prepared to
compromise on its red lines as well I
mean is a second referendum or if you
prefer to call it a complementary vote
on any deal a red line for the Labour
Party in these negotiations
well a confirmatory voters clearly got
huge support amongst parliamentarians
but the Labour parliamentarians
particularly we've seen that in the in
the newspapers today it's got huge
support amongst the party membership and
we've always said that if we cannot get
a customs union arrangement customers
Union deal and a single market
arrangement if it looks like we're going
to have a bad Tory deal or indeed no
deal which will be disastrous for the
for the British economy and people's
jobs and livelihoods then then it should
be put to the British people in a
confirmation vote so we should put it
back to the British people so look but
at the moment we are trying to negotiate
in good faith a deal with the government
which secures a permanent customs union
which allows us to have a say in trade
deals in the opinion because we don't
that as I say there's a real danger that
we can have a trade deal with for
example the US which puts the NHS or
casel and I'm not prepared